hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my Sherlock episode 2 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet big major reveals there
is a new round of the Sherlock giveaway
is just a $20 Amazon gift card all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video
winners are usually announced at the end
so be sure to click that bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything so
many big reveals there's something about
the number 3 people just stop looking so
we learned about the third sibling with
a teaser you know maybe there might be a
fourth because people stopped looking
after three we just met the third in her
name is euros not share inferred which
is on Mycroft pad so the actual episode
title itself The Lying detective is an
Easter Egg for the adventure of the
dying detective which is a culverton
Smith story so the basic plot of how
Sherlock tries to trick culverton into
getting a confession out of him is
basically lifted right out of that
original Holmes story in the book
version Sherlock just suspects him of
his nephews murder instead of being like
an outright serial killer but the way
the book describes him just is so
perfect the way toby jones looks is just
so creepy so this is actually how it
reads in the book with the shrill cry of
anger a man rose from a reclining chair
beside the fire I saw a great yellow
face coarse-grained and greasy with
heavy double chin and two sullen
menacing grey eyes which glared at me
from under tufted and sandy brows a high
bald head had a small velvet smoking cap
poised upon one side of its pink curve
the school was of enormous capacity and
yet as I looked down and saw to my
amazement that the figure of the man was
small and frail twisted in the shoulders
in a back like one who had suffered from
rickets in his childhood so he's
essentially describing Gollum from The
Lord of the Rings an upstanding member
of the community who seems like this
really impish horrifying figure that
just screams villain like you look at
him and you just know that something's
off so the cinematography the costume
design the makeup everything looked
amazing in this episode it was so trippy
but you have to remember the
Sherlock was on drugs so that he could
go to hell as Mary had asked him and for
some reason I missed the post-credits
scene after the last episode so I didn't
learn about it till after the episode
aired but the guess was is that she was
giving him directions like she wasn't
cursing him she was telling him to go to
the place that is hell so we got the
explainer for that and it was a
roundabout way to save John Watson by
having him save Sherlock so it worked
and we finally found out what was up
with Watson texting that mystery female
witch surprise surprise was the secret
sibling of Mycroft and Sherlock not to
be confused with Sharon Ford because
when she is saying all the names of her
family members she leaves out Sharon
furred who I am
isn't it obvious haven't you guessed I'm
URIs George silly name isn't it Greek
means the east wind my parents loved
silly names like you Ross or Mycroft
or Sherlock
I'll look at him didn't it ever occur to
you not even once that Sherlock secret
rather might just be Sherlock secret
sister in share inferred the theoretical
third brother is supposed to be even
smarter than Mycroft like Sherlock is
smart Mycroft is even smarter in share
inferred is supposed to be this towering
intellect above all of them was
originally the name that Arthur Conan
Doyle was going to named Sherlock his
main character but then changed it the
character doesn't literally exist in the
Canon of the books it was just a
theoretical creation to explain why
Sherlock and Mycroft weren't forced to
follow their parents in their chosen
profession and were able to go off and
do the things that they did during the
novel's so share inferred was something
that was added after the fact to sort of
clean up the logic of the stories just a
little bit but because the producers
pull from all over Sherlock Canon and
because they had that very special line
everyone stops looking after three
there's the theory that they will
actually do share inferred on the TV
show people kept thinking that it was
going to be Tom Hiddleston they
interviewed him at the Golden Globes and
he's like why do people keep saying that
I'm not doing Sherlock I'm not on that
TV show
so the third secret sibling in this
episode euros is probably the person
that Mycroft is referring to when he
says the other one someone who is kept
locked in a tower as John Watson jokes
so by the end of the episode the way she
explains it is that she left Sherlock a
lot of clues so when he's deducing
things about her like she lives in a
very small room because of the way the
papers folded in the way the sunlight
fell on it you kind of have to take that
with a grain of salt because like the
literal name of the episode The Lying
detective she's lying quite a bit and
she was lying to Sherlock so it's hard
to know exactly what her backstory is
but presumably we'll find out in the
next episode because of that major
cliffhanger the crazy thing if you
missed it is she says that a mutual
friend put her in touch with culverton
which gave her faiths original note like
the actual daughter of culverton who
sherlock thought he was meeting with so
the note itself was authentic
but euros here sounds like she might
have been working with Moriarty because
of the miss me so even though Sherlock
is playing
Moriarty's great
game his sibling is a part of it so you
see how they're like twisting this
making this a very tight family affair
just heightening the drama that way so
Sherlock is gonna have to take someone
down by the end of the series possibly
kill someone again and it sounds like it
might end up being his sister which is
all the more tragic which is you know
very in keeping with the tone of the
series
so the culverton plot is still ongoing
like he just keeps confessing like he'll
totally walk off scot-free it's like
during series 2 where Moriarty was like
very happy to give himself over to the
police like he wanted to get caught
because he knew he would be able to get
off so as culverton says he has all this
money wealth he's very tight with the
Queen he could get off scot-free if he
wants so he can't stop confessing even
though Sherlock says that their evidence
is inadmissible
so the culverton plot will carry over
into the next episode as well as
sherlock and mycroft sisters so wasn't
all completely WTF I love the way they
use Mary in this episode and mrs. Hudson
was amazing of course that's my car I
was married to a drug dealer
no you can't borrow it in fact she
actually solves the mystery of Sherlock
for Mycroft she's like look what is
Sherlock do when he can't solve a
mystery he stabs something he shoots the
wall so she was just a complete badass
in this episode and it was a great way
to open it - with that car chase scene
where she just gets out and then
surprise surprise Sherlock is in the
boot so even though it was a drug-fueled
tour-de-force
there was a lot of humour in the episode
but let me know in the comments do you
actually think that they're going to
reveal Sharon Ford is the secret fourth
Holmes sibling they'll be like a crazy
WTF everybody stops looking after three
and I almost forgot
Irene Adler is still very much a part of
the series he even admitted to texting
her in moments of weakness he's like
we're all human John when he was trying
to explain that even though Watson was
cheating on his wife by texting he was a
human being everyone is human so they
finally revealed when his birthday was
no idea if they intend to actually
physically bring her on in an episode I
don't know if Laura Pulver the actress
was available but it would be amazing
for the fans especially if they're not
going to do another season of Sherlock
for a while they haven't really
announced what their plans
are after this season so we can talk
about that when I post my finale video
but it would be a lot of fun
speaking of which congratulations to
this week's giveaway winner Stephen
Montez you win a $20 Amazon gift card
just be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details there's a new round
that started in this video so I just
announced the winner the next time I
post a Sherlock video so new episode
posting next week who knows maybe
they'll surprise us and they'll be like
a secret 4th episode but I'm not
expecting that well you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for my
Sherlock episode 1 video and you can
click here for all the other crazy stuff
that's coming up you guys need to get
really excited about thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys in the
next video